psychologists would talk about the kind
of the trauma bond that exists when
we've been used to a parent that
neglected us or that was very hot and
cold in our lives and that becomes kind
of what we know and so we get attracted
to that behavior in others and we try
and complete a journey that never felt
finished When We Were Young and so we
also have to be very careful of what
we're labeling attraction am I labeling
this trauma and this heightened sense of
anxiety that I have around you because
you're fickle and you never make me feel
secure am I labeling that excitement
well I I just what is it I've got with
this person I and the more they don't
call me the more I'm like oh they
there's something special about this one
why is it why are they getting more
attractive the less they try what's
going on here we have to really suspect
those things in ourselves